Game of Thrones Season seven episode 5
begins with Jamie washing ashore like
Aragorn in two towers but instead of a
sexy dream elf to wake him he's got
brawn listen to me [ __ ] Bronn points out
the obvious
the Lannisters can't be Daenerys with
her three dragons so Jamie goes to
Cersei and says they can't win this war
but Cersei won't surrender she says
there's too much bad blood to make peace
so she won't forgive Terry for killing
her father Tywin Danny won't forgive
Jaime for killing her father Aerys and
Cersei refuses to let go of the Iron
Throne
Tyrion Lannister walks through the ashes
of his family's army and he seems to
feel some regret then again Tyrion did
promise Cersei that one day he'd turn
her joy to ashes
perhaps that day has come Tyrion turned
Sosa's power to dust the Lannister army
was also the pride of Tyrion hated
father Tywin
maybe Tyrion Fields and satisfaction
wiping the last trace of his father's
legacy
Daenerys till for surviving Lannisters
that she's not there to burn or murder
and then she murders Randall and dick on
by burning them in front of their men
tyrians a bit worried that this sends
mixed messages good leaders sometimes do
have to kill disloyal Lords Rob and John
both did but burning a father and son
alive reminds people of Danny's father
mad Aerys who killed Rica and Brandon
stark it's a delicate balance between
being a strong leader and looking like a
terrible tyrant especially with the
memory of Aerys hanging over you Danny
talks about making the world better and
breaking the wheel metaphor for stopping
the cycle of conflict in Westeros and
changing the political system somehow
it's not really clear what kind of
changes Danny wants to make remember
this is her first day on the Westerosi
mainland she's a stranger to this
country she doesn't know its problems so
how can she hope to reshape society for
the better look what she did in Mereen
she came to a foreign city destroyed its
social structure banned slavery made
herself Queen and tried to make
everything fair and it was a disaster
the sons of the harpy revolted the
slavers attacked in force and Dany ended
up leaving with Dario in charge
since we haven't heard any updates from
Dario's Democratic Republic of the bay
of dragons lately it's probably fair to
assume that things have turned bad in
Moran just like they did in a stupor and
young Chi the point is Danny's speech
may be good political rhetoric but we
know that ruling Westeros won't be so
simple Danny returns to Dragonstone and
John has a moment with a dragon dragon
in the books it's hinted that dragons
tend to be more friendly to people who
have Targaryen blood so it may be drogon
is nice to John because John is the son
of Rhaegar Targaryen then again
the dragons were also cool with Tyrion
and he's not a Targaryen probably so
this might not necessarily mean a whole
lot
Dany asks again about Jon's death and
Jon avoids the question again then he's
going to have to find out some time
about Jon's resurrection she's had a
magical rebirth or two herself so she
probably would understand
Dany and Jon a Fire and Ice and sometime
they're going to have to recognize it
but they're interrupted by the arrival
of Jorah now healed of his greyscale
Dany and Jorah have a long and
complicated history
Dany exiled Jorah in season four for
reporting on her to Varys he returned to
her briefly in season five but she
didn't forgive him for a while they
reunited in season six but Jorah had
greyscale and had to get cured and now
he's back once again Jorah loves Dany
and in the books this comes off as
creepy Danny's a teenager and jaw is
this fugly middle-aged man who hits on
her because she looks like his ex-wife
but still Jorah has stayed loyal to Dany
longer than anyone else has they've been
through a lot together so Danny wants
him by her side in the north bran uses
his magic powers to take control of a
bunch of Ravens he flies them over the
wall and looks at the army of the Dead
until the night King seems to break
brand's control if the night king can
break brand's control of ravens could
bran break the night Kings control of
these zombies just deactivate the whole
army of the Dead at once how'd it be
handy we still don't really know how
this magic works it does seem that
Brandon the night king use a similar
kind of magic which might suggest that
this human who became the night King
years ago was originally a
greenseer like bran and bloodraven in
the books bran sees a vision of the
bones of other dreamers impaled on ice
maybe the other white walkers were
originally green seers who turned to the
icy dark side of old gods magic on
denied King Darth Vader or something
after all this time the walkers are
still super mysterious so it'll be
awesome to find out more about what they
are and what they want
bran sees that the walkers are marching
on east watch the easternmost castle on
the wall emphasis on the wall the east
watch is behind it and the wall is
protected with magic which apparently
stops the dead getting through so they
probably can't just bash down the gate
with an undead giant how then will the
walkers pass the wall in the opening
credits of past episodes the ocean by
the wall has looked frozen over so some
people think that they could maybe just
walk around atop the sea or maybe do an
underwater Pirates of the Caribbean
thing it probably would have been easier
though for the Dead to just go west
instead because to the West the wall
ends and there's a bridge across a gorge
why not cross there the walkers must
have some special plan to get past east
watch so bran sends out some letters to
warn everyone down at the Citadel the
mesas want to see evidence before they
freaked out about magic zombies which in
the real world would be very reasonable
but in fantasy skeptics are wrong the
most has mentioned other prophets from
the past like Jenny of old stones Jenny
was a mysterious common woman who
married a Targaryen Prince about 50
years ago Jenny was friends with a witch
now known as the ghost of high heart who
said that the prince that was promised
or azor Ahai would be born from the line
of Aries and Rey Ella which means that
either Daenerys or John could be the
hero to save the world
looks like Jenny was probably right the
maesters also mention a guy called la
das three hundred years ago when the
Targaryen took the Iron Islands la das
claimed he was the son of the drowned
God and that Krakens would rise up to
destroy Aegon's fleet I didn't happen
and Lourdes led a mass suicide but in
the books Krakens have been seen
recently and it's looking like book
urine might just turn himself into some
kind of Cthulhu so maybe even la das was
onto something
point is both of the arch maces examples
of prophecy being wrong might actually
have elements of truth but they still
don't believe in the White Walkers as
frustrated Sam so much that he abandons
his dream of becoming a maester steals
in books and heads north to somehow help
in the war for the dawn he presumably
brings the sword hearts pain with him
Sam's father Randall won't be needing it
anymore
there's not much love lost between
Randall and Sam but Dickinson door right
so some might mourn the loss of his
brother before Sam leaves though Gilly
quietly drops the biggest revelation of
the season she reads in a book that a
Septon annulled the marriage of Prince
Rhaegar and married him to someone else
in a secret ceremony in Dorne
what this means is that Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen Daenerys his older brother set
aside his marriage to Elia Martell and
secretly married Lyanna stark who gave
birth to Jon Snow in Dorne
fans have speculated for years that
something like this had happened because
this means that Jon Snow is not really a
bastard he's a legitimate child of
Prince Rhaegar making him the legitimate
heir of King Aerys meaning Jon Snow
should be the king of all Westeros this
complicates the situation with Jon's
aunt Daenerys who also claims the throne
no one in the story actually knows all
of this does so we'll have to wait until
bran or someone figures it out at
Dragonstone Tyrion and Varys worry that
Dany might become a bad ruler like a
father Aerys and Varys doesn't seem to
know what to do about this Varys used to
seemed so powerful a secretive schemer
spymaster and spider who knew everything
and made everyone his puppet but now
that he's revealed his hand and made his
loyalties clear Varys is just a bald guy
in a dressing gown hoping for the best
he did always say that power is an
illusion John and Danny and Tyrion work
out a plan John will lead a team beyond
the wall to capture a zombie and bring
it down to King's Landing to show Cersei
so that Cersei will help them or at
least not attack them or something when
they go back north to fight against the
dead and this plan is bad it's a huge
risk to King John and he's the guy
uniting the
or from the wildlings and Daenerys and
if they succeed in catching a zombie
there's no guarantee it'll stay animated
on the long journey south
it might rot or get out of range of the
walkers magic or just stop moving even
if all that works out all they'd
actually achieve is to show Cersei a
zombie
why would certain prayers when she's
already got a zombie the mountain one
zombie doesn't prove the threat of the
army of the Dead
even if Cersei does believe it does
anyone really think that so she would
make peace with her enemies for the sake
of the greater good even if she does
what will her help even be worth Danny
just roasted a Lannister army how many
men can Cersei have left how useful will
soldiers be against the army of the Dead
anyway the best way to beat the dead
would surely be Dany's dragons why not
just fly up and burn them all now or if
you just want to capture a zombie why
not swoop down with a dragon and grab
one the answer to these questions of
course is the same reason that Eagles
don't fly Frodo to Mount Doom it would
be too easy and too quick but part of
what makes Game of Thrones special and
different to fantasies like Lord of the
Rings is that behind all the dragons and
zombies there's usually a strong logic
to the plot people make decisions that
make sense and this convoluted dangerous
probably pointless plan does not make
much sense at Winterfell the Lords of
the north and the Vale speak in support
of Sansa it almost sounds like they want
to declare her their queen when only
last season they declared Jon their king
before that they mostly supported the
Bolton's and before that they supported
Robb Stark seems they can't go a whole
season without wanting to change sides
I accuses Sansa of undermining Jon and
wanting power for herself
Sansa tries to be reasonable but I urge
just won't listen it makes sense that I
had doesn't really get the politics she
has spent seasons training with
assassins not learning diplomacy but
this seems rooted in something deeper
for hire she criticizes answer for
loving pretty things and feeling
superior which connects to the jealousy
and resentment I had for Sansa growing
up over how Sansa was perfect and pretty
while iron never fit maybe the real
reason fires
ration is all this old anger whatever
the reason Littlefinger sees an
opportunity he manipulates iya into
finding an old letter that Circe made
Sansa writes aborting King Joffrey and
condemning the Starks this wasn't really
Santa's fault she was just a kid and she
had no real choice but this might work
as a way for Peter to isolate Sansa from
the rest of her family to create chaos
and division which he could use to gain
more influence this is some classic
Petyr Baelish evil scheming and in the
short term it might just work
but in the long term Sansa can just
explain how she was forced to write the
letter Eyre can figure out that Peter
misled her and bran can reveal that he's
magically seen every evil thing little
thing is done so little fingers [ __ ]
but at least he gets one last lurkin
tyrion and davos arrive at King's
Landing and Davos mentions the death of
his son math ox in season two Davos has
a wife and kids back home and he often
thinks about them in the books but while
everyone else complains about their
personal drama all the time Devils
usually keeps things to himself and
carries on his duty but he still
remembers his friends Davos goes and
meets with Gendry the bastard son of
King Robert who was last seen rolling in
season 3 after Melisandre tried to burn
him Gendry wields a war hammer just like
his father did decorated with the stag
of his house
it looks like Gendry identifies with his
father's family the Baratheon's maybe
after the war is won he'll rule the
Baratheon seat of storms end since every
other Baratheon is dead as the son of
King Robert 3rd Gendry could also
potentially have a claim on the Iron
Throne which shows devil says
complicates the situation with John and
Danny meanwhile Tyrion goes to meet
Jamie
Tyrion tries to justify the killing of
their father Tywin but Jamie doesn't
want to hear it and threatens to kill
Tyrion the brothers relationship in the
books is even worse they parted on bad
terms with Tyrion lying and saying he
killed Joffrey
so the reunion in the books might be a
lot darker
anyway Tyrion gets to the point and asks
Jamie to convince Cersei to peacefully
meet with Danny and Jon on the way out
Davos and go have some trouble with gold
cloaks
it really was a big risk
coming here in broad daylight with super
recognizable imp they could easily have
all been caught and killed by [ __ ] but
Kendra solves their problems with his
hammer and they get away
Jamie reveals to Cersei that he met
Tyrion and so she reveals to Jamie that
she already knew and allowed it to
happen
which is pretty surprising so she hates
and fears Tyrion more than anyone else
in the world you'd think she'd take the
chance to kill him but apparently so she
decided she needs to make peace with
Daenerys to beat her in the long run so
she tells Jaime that she's pregnant and
the twins share an emotional moment
which says he immediately exploits to
tell Jaime to never betray her so this
is some classic emotional manipulation
from Cersei using a tender moment for
strategic gain but there's also probably
some sincerity here Circe's pregnancy
might help explain why Cersei went from
wanting to fight to the death to wanting
peace within one episode she has a child
to protect now but the pregnancy also
raises some questions
Maggy the Frog predicted that says he
would have three children a fourth child
would go against that prophecy in the
show so she did have a short live baby
with Robert so maybe that numbers out
the window anyway but still it would be
weird if says he had another child
maybe she'll die before it's born but if
the Vallon gua theory is true and Jamie
kills Cersei would he kill his own
unborn child along with his twin this
baby raises the stakes at Dragonstone
Jon meets kendry Kendra's father Robert
and Jon's supposed father Ned were close
friends and their bond inspires a
friendship between Gendry and Jon
Kendra's keen to join the fight against
the dead which is a little surprising
given that he has no experience with
White Walkers or with the north but
Gendry has seen some mystical [ __ ] what
with beric and the red witch so it's
plausible enough that he believes in the
dead if it gives him something to swing
at Tyrion fails Jorah and hints at their
rocky past remember that one time Jorah
dwarf nabbed Tyrion and Dany farewell
Jorah for the umpteenth time maybe for
the last time and finally Dany farewells
Jon with a longing gaze it had saved a
lot of hassle if these guys just had me
that they want to bone because a
marriage alliance between Danny and John
would be hugely powerful it would clear
up the problem of their competing claims
on the Iron Throne and they could rule
together as king and queen chuck Gendry
in there for a threesome and you'd solve
the whole succession crisis in one go
but might have to leave that for the
fanfic Attis watch John forms the
greatest squad of warriors Westeros has
ever seen there's Jon Snow the White
Wolf the resurrected King in the north
Gendry the bull bastard son of King
Robert Thoros the red wizard of Muir and
beric Dondarrion the lightning Lord six
times reborn as Jorah Mormont
so friendzone survivor of greyscale
tormund Giantsbane husband two bears
meet king of ruddy hall and Sandor
Clegane the Hound
gravedigger and eater of chicken it's an
amazing team which ordinarily would be
impossible because these guys are
Knights & wildlings northerners and
southerners followers of the old gods
and of real law there's a lot of bad
blood here Gendry was sold to Melisandre
by Thoris and Berek Berek was killed by
the Hound then resurrected Tolman's
people were hunted and killed by Joris
father John Mormont any other time these
guys would be enemies but because of the
threat of the dead none of these grudges
matter anymore which kind of says it all
about this new season there's no time
for the complexity the history or the
logistics the story is hurtling towards
its climax
there is something lost when the show
moves so fast but it is a lot of fun to
watch the heroes step beyond the wall to
face the night this scene when Cersei
made Santa write a letter against the
Starks is a really interesting chapter
of The Game of Thrones books it shows
how naive and trusting Sansa once was
and how manipulative Cersei is using
love to assure loyalty just like she
does with Jaime in this episode you can
listen to this chapter on audiobook for
free today with our sponsor audible by
signing up for a trial at audible.com
slash ASX you get a free audiobook to
keep even if you cancel the trial and it
helps out this channel so sign up at the
link below
thanks for watching thanks to the
translators for translating captions and
thanks to patrons Cara shadow Valentin
Deegan disco Dan Gerald Callahan Bruno
Soares II and Samantha suave Cheers
you